لاول مره نتمكن من الوصول لهذه المنطقه في
منطقه حي السلام هنا شرق جباليا هذه
النقطه الفاصله ما بين شرق جباليا ومنطقه
التفاح كما نشاهد هنا من خلف جبل الريس
هنا كانت تتوغل قوات الاحتلال والياته حيث
هنا ايضا ارت الاشتباكات بين المقاومه
الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال لمده طويله في
هذه المنطقه وهنا توغلت قوات الاحتلال
وايضا قامت بتدمير وتجريف جميع الطرقات
وتدمير جميع المنازل في هذه المنطقه نشاهد
امامنا هنا جبل الريس التي كانت تتواجد به
قوات الاحتلال لمده طويله ايضا نشاهد حجم
هذا الدمار في هذه
المنطقه نتيجه توغل قوات الاحتلال في
منطقه حي السلام هنا شرق
جباليا الدمار كبير جدا الذي خلفته قوات
الاحتلال نتيجه هذا التوغل في هذه المنطقه
هنا الدمار طال كل شيء طال الشوارع وطال
الطرقات وطال البنيه التحتيه بالكامل
والله زي ما انت شايف كل هذا دمار فيش دار
تصلح تقعد
فيها امسك من القرم هذا منطقه حي السلام
امسك من القرم للسلك من ارض
لدار لشجر لبيوت كله دمار فش شيء يصلح
للسكن
يعني انت بتيجي بتقعدين بشارع بتقعد بدنا
نقعد في الشوارع احنا ان شاء الله نضلنا
صامدين ونظل بعزيمتها القويه باذن الله عز
وجل وان شاء الله حنرجع اقوى من الاول
نشاهد هنا حجم هذا
الدمار بسبب توغل قوات الاحتلال في هذه
المنطقه الدمار هنا طال كل شيء طال
المصانع وطال المنازل وطال الشوارع كما
نشاهد طبعا هذا المسجد مسجد الصديق من
اقدم المساجد هنا في شمال قطاع غزه تم
تدميره من قبل قوات
الاحتلال اذا هذا ما خلفته قوات الاحتلال
بعد انسحابها من منطقه حي السلام شرق
جباليا دمار وخراب طال المساجد والمباني
والشوارع وال
انس الشريف الجزيره شمال غزه